now on forward what lies ahead for the
us economy and what you and yours should
be thinking about doing zach and i talk
about shootings is this time different
and we make summer content
recommendations including zach's
experience as a first-time author this
week on forward
[Music]
and we are back
to talk about the changing world order
my conversation with perhaps the world's
greatest investor certainly on the top
five or ten list ray dalio what the heck
this book actually means wow
did i find interviewing ray dalio to be
edifying and fascinating uh and for
those of you who missed it you can check
that out or you can check out the
youtube video
that summarizes his new book principles
for dealing with the changing world
order or if you're like me and you want
to inhale a 430 page book you can buy
ray's book but i
came away from this interview with like
my worldview having changed all right we
were talking about this before we
started recording is that if you're a
billionaire
and like a very successful well-known
billionaire right
there's no real point in writing a book
from a money or status prestige
situation so the only reason he's
writing it is because he's got something
to say and i feel like if you got a guy
like that who's pretty wise you should
probably listen you know and given what
i've taken away from the book in the
podcast
yeah listen up y'all feeling like it's
crazy you felt like a real life oracle
because check it out bounds the world's
biggest hedge fund yeah that now has
over 200 billion under management i mean
that's literally like nation state scale
stuff
personally worth
20 plus billion dollars uh and it did
all this without frankly any notoriety
uh you know it's like he he does not
need the spotlight to your point yeah
and he talked several times in his book
about how it's like hey some people
aren't going to like this but you know i
i think it's important to share
because he he knows frankly how
polarizing everything is
and the rest of it but his points his
big points were that there are three
mega cycles
that
the u.s is going through uh and
unfortunately
all three of them bode ill for our
relatively near future and he talks
about this as a world-class investor
who's like look sometimes the time
horizon is longer than your lifetime but
the things can happen in your lifetime
so you have to understand them
and he talks about how early in his
career the the us dollar got devalued
when they left the gold standard and he
was like okay that's new so that was in
the early 70s and he's very very
concerned that we're doing it again that
we're going through a massive
devaluation what's interesting is
listening to him talk i
heard many many crypto enthusiasts
talking as well because there are a lot
of folks who are into crypto who are
like hey they're debasing the dollar
they're basing the dollar right and
uh one of the things that
ray talks about is that since 1700
75 of the currencies that were in effect
uh over that time have ceased to exist
that typically a currency goes through
this grand arc and then eventually the
currency
either stops existing because it doesn't
work anymore or it's been greatly
devalued so he says the 25 of the
currencies that are still ineffective
and greatly devalued but three out of
four of them just don't exist anymore
that's terrifying and so he talks about
the the six part cycle of uh it's like
the mega credit cycle it takes 50 to 75
years and and one of the things that
when i was running for president this
reminded me of is that back in sumerian
times uh
you you know this
uh word jubilee jubilation jubilee
so that originated venus what does it
mean ultimate celebration well well that
originated as a giant debt forgiveness
festival
that happened in like ancient times
where the cycle of things that happened
was that people
started borrowing money and then
borrowing money and then they borrowed
too much money and then they showed up
uh to the king and started rioting being
like hey we owe too much money and then
the king would come out and say i
forgive all the debts and they would
have a giant party that's what the
jubilee was
so this goes by yeah this goes back to
ancient times where the the the cycle is
that a currency starts out as a hard
currency
where back in the day it might have been
gold it might have been you know pieces
of food i mean like they're different
things and then eventually you end up
with notes that are against the gold
because gold's inconvenient to actually
trade in coins and whatnot and then
eventually it becomes fiat currency
which is where we
went to when we switched off the gold
standard where the government has the
ability to print it and then when you
have the ability to print it you always
print too much
and then it starts getting debased and
so if you're a small country and it gets
debased and sometimes things spill out
of control and then you wind up having
to reset which is the last part of the
cycle you have runs on banks and then
the government has to be like okay okay
you know this currency that's losing
value
that's not it
anymore we're going back to a hard
currency gold standard and you can trust
it because this time we're backing it up
with something real and then everyone's
like okay okay
so the the issue with the us right now
is that no one knows where this
particular cycle ends because
you can't leave the dollar and so this
is one of the arguments he makes in this
book that also blew my mind was like
look he goes through the world's
currencies and is like
you know the eu like too small and weak
uh the renminbi like you know china has
these weird currency controls the yen
like no one cares like that but it's
like there is no other global reserve
currency candidate that makes any sense
uh and so the u.s is like well what are
you going to do like got to use a dollar
because there's no place else to go
and this in a way to me was the
uh genesis of crypto where people are
casting about for an alternative to the
dollar and then you know wound up with
bitcoin which starts out as essentially
a digital version of gold the other big
alternative is gold itself
uh which rey
owns at least some gold so that
certainly made me think like huh
listening to him talk i was like [ __ ]
like you know like gold actually it has
like a more appealing case based on the
conversation
so one of the issues with crypto
unfortunately is that
it's not clear whether it is truly uh
hedging against currency risk
because it seems right now to correlate
more with certain other assets frankly
uh that than risk assets yeah yeah like
risky assets than it does like a basket
of currencies
so the the
multi-trillion dollar question is what
happens
when you have a us dollar global reserve
currency that uh is being overproduced
shall we say like you know that we're
printing a lot of it um and but you
don't have any place to go so the
argument that rey makes is that capital
will find a place to go that like it's
not obvious that there's another
currency but that you will
it will leave the dollar if people sense
the dollars losing value what happened
to uh modern monetary theory or some of
the stuff we thought on the campaign
where
as long as the federal government us
government is strong
and pays its debt and we can pretty much
just
it's not real uh but we can just kind of
have as much to be we want uh but i'm
blatantly oversimplifying modern
monetary theory but your thoughts on
that now and is that
no longer the case were we wrong like
what's
you know what's your thoughts so ray's
case is that you're looking at
historical examples over and over again
and
they always end up playing out
similarly right
which would frankly
contradict modern monetary theory
um if modern monetary theory does hold
then you know we're in a whole new era
but he makes a very very convincing
historical case that we've seen this
movie before
and that there were two major global
reserve currencies before us
uh the
pound when the uk owned 25 percent of
the world and was running around
an outside empire
which pre preceded ours immediately and
then before this that that i didn't know
this but apparently the dutch gilder was
the global reserve currency for a while
when like the dutch traders ran
everything got it uh so his argument is
that you know that we're going to go
through some and the the scenarios he
plays out frankly are very very
difficult and dark but this does go back
to the central political question of the
time which is what the heck you do about
inflation right joe biden recently
announced his plan to combat inflation
in an op-ed that was
vastly panned honestly
because
uh he he was in some ways
pushing responsibility onto other actors
which in a way is totally legitimate
because there may be real limits to what
he can do but uh that's not exactly the
plan people want to hear where it's like
you know
you you want
um something that the person can
actually execute on um so the two other
major players in this scenario are
congress and the fed
and
they may have more power over what
happens
uh in terms of inflation than anything
joe biden can do though no one wants to
necessarily hear that it's so funny how
we
i can't even say the difference between
when he ran for mayor when we ran for
president in terms of
how many people care about the president
and they're so passionate they identify
with the president as a role and
you know it's the running joke blame
obama or blame whoever you want right
for various problems but the reality is
and we live it and seeing it right now
is the president has
only a few levers to pull and the
reality is they're pretty subject to
macroeconomic forces our economy in
general and what congress can or can't
or won't do
what's your outlook on
both inflation our economy in general
we're heading i'm assuming we're heading
towards a recession for i guess we're in
it right now
uh how i think you're it sounds like
you're saying this gets worse before it
gets better how worse how much worse
does it get i've now spoken to
a number of
leading
investors so david rubinstein was on the
podcast
you know ray is obviously
in this category
and i've talked to some other figures
who maybe aren't quite as prominent or
famous
the the theme they keep pointing out is
look you're going to have to raise
interest rates in order for
[Music]
inflation to come down at all
and if you do raise interest rates which
better have been anomalously low for an
extended period of time
in a way that's essentially unique in in
modern history
um if you raise interest rates
significantly the current stock market
valuations do not make any sense because
they're getting discounted forward
uh with like a very very low
time value of money so if you jack up
the time value of money then a lot of
tech companies valuations don't make
sense a lot a lot of growth companies
valuations don't make sense so you want
to end up with a stock market correction
of a very very significant nature
and then you wind up with a recession of
some kind
and i do not see any way out of this i
think we're going to end up with a very
significant recession
and the adjustments are going to be
deeply deeply painful
have you ever heard of data brokers well
they've heard of you they are the
middlemen that collect and sell the
digital footprints that you leave online
they make detailed profiles and then
they sell your browsing history and your
online searches even your location data
to any company that wants to target you
does this sound like a good time it
doesn't sound like a good time to me
and one way to protect yourself is to do
what i do and use express vpn it's one
of the easiest ways to get your own data
under your control when you're connected
to expressvpn your ip address is hidden
high-end corporations use this for their
people it encrypts 100 of network
traffic to keep your data safe so make
sure your online activity and data are
protected with the best vpn money can
buy visit
expressvpn.com yang right now and get
three extra months free through my
special link that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
yang
expressvpn.com yang to learn more
[Music]
at least from my perspective what i'm
studying
uh my limited amount of study from
learning on wall street is that those
guys like the warren buffett's and the
ray dalys of the world
they don't seem that their timing is
sometimes wrong
but over time they're
at least from what i've seen they're
never really wrong
there's always there's some greedy
investor like things are changing this
is different you don't understand amazon
and they're like you can value it xyz
and then eventually it all comes back
down to earth and then your raid alleys
of the world you're like i told you so i
guess my real question is i don't think
i got an answer from you like modern
monetary theory or like ray dalio's
right if you're looking at these two
camps like i'm assuming you're on the
side of ray's probably right and this
the currencies are uh we're gonna have a
currency pretty soon i will say that ray
makes a very very compelling case
based upon
based upon
not decades but centuries of history
yeah
he goes way back and so imagine this too
imagine that you ran a 200 billion hedge
fund he literally has an army of
researchers who can pull up just about
anything you know so this book is
literally like 400 you know um yeah 50
pages or something along those lines did
ray dalio sit there and write 450 pages
of course not like it's filled with
uh data sets and tables oh interesting
because he has like a like an army of
people being like hey i'm going to pull
up i got a report here i'm going to pull
up a report on the dutch gilder or
whatever you can see how it like relates
to gold got it and so so there there's
so much data in here
that if you respect data at all you look
at this and you're like well like it's
essentially inarguable
like like if you
you know i mean it's like a 450 page uh
argument that's documented back hundreds
of years so it's it's very hard to look
at this and be like yeah this guy's
you know somehow uh barking at the wind
you know like it it's hard to compute
that it's one of the things where i you
know like theoretically anybody can
invest in the stock market right you and
i zach joe schmuck can buy
apple and buy things and try and play
the game and be a smart investor
but the difference that these ins the
inherent advantages that these
institutional investors have
like we can the average investor the
average person cannot wrap their mind
around and what i mean by that i
remember
talk because i used to talk to a
research analyst all the time for
example i think it was apollo or sorry
it was blackrock or one of the big
private equity shops
and they were like blackstone
and they were like
you know the reason people think they
know where the market's going and this
the other thing we know where the market
is right now because we know how many
sandwiches subway sold yesterday like we
know this real-time data of what's going
on we know how many packages of x that
amazon has sold whatever it is and
that's data that either the average
human doesn't have or doesn't have the
manpower to actually like sift through
so usually these like re like these
investors that stood the test of time
and they're looking at the numbers
they're usually
directionally accurate you know so one
of the things that came out just
the last several days
was that
elon musk said there's something very
very bad brewing in the economy
jamie dimon says that there is a
hurricane coming you should brace
yourself we just don't know what size
the hurricane is
and then joe biden got asked about this
and then
said
uh well intel's hiring
ford's hiring
uh you know economies strong economy is
good fundamentals are good etc and and
one of the major problems we have in
american life today is that everyone
needs to talk up their case
it's like because there are so many
people right now that are in the
administration or around the
administration who are essentially
making like a bullish case for various
things and you can point to various
measurements and say oh job growth's up
like you know there are different things
that are happening i mean right now
essentially like 70 of americans are not
pleased with the direction because right
they just look at the price of gas and
then yeah that's like you know like
that's day-to-day life and it's tough um
but you have different people whose
interests and the thing is like if like
you know i like i were joe biden like
you do have to make a positive case
you know and and the rest of it so that
that's one of like the
the struggles is like you like we've
essentially politicized what's going on
in the economy yes uh and derek thompson
when i interviewed him talked about how
like your perception of the economy is
actually very much partisan yep uh it
just depends on how you feel about who's
in office so the people who don't like
uh joe biden the democrats think
economy's super terrible and then and
then you know joan the democrats will
talk about how uh there are some bright
spots i'm so one of the reasons why i
want to talk about this is like for the
folks who listen to me
like andrew yang thinks that there are
some very very very ominous dark clouds
and weaknesses coming
on a scale that
we have not seen in quite some time and
so please do act accordingly like you
know like if you
uh have assets out there that
you know you feel like uh frankly are
kind of at risk or things that you might
want you might need over like you know
some
uh period of of weeks or months like i
personally would say you know you might
want to
like bring those assets in uh do some
things
because i i think that if you hear ray
dalio and jamie dimon uh and elon all
say something like to me it's like and
by the way like my intuition is also
very much heading in that direction
right um that and this isn't a partisan
thing this is just like i think this is
i think shit's gonna get nasty i think
like really dark and nasty in the spirit
of more positive news ray also talks
about in his book
essentially a 30 percent chance of a
civil war or civil unrest in the united
states
it's a war yeah
stage six is what he calls it jesus that
we're in stage five of six and was it
tied to the economy or just simply
because of polarization and this
changing world order so just like
there's a mega credit cycle that has six
stages apparently there's uh an internal
order disorder cycle that has six stages
and it's tied to public use of resources
so there's a pre peace and prosperity
phase in stage three and then stage four
involves
excess debt and unproductive use of
resources stage five which we're in
right now is called the decline where
you have internal conflicts and debt
problems and then stage six is a civil
war
slash unrest and during my interview
with him i said to him it's like hey ray
you said in your book 30 chance i mean
that's staggeringly high and he was like
oh it's higher now oh god because he
wrote this probably you know
12 18 months ago and this is also a mega
cycle that takes like you know a number
of decades
he talked about what you would need to
counteract it said that there are two
types of outcomes the more likely
outcome is
a nasty populist uh type uh strongman
figure and then the benign case is what
he called the strong peacemaker but when
he looked throughout history he found
very few examples of the strong
peacemaker more nasty populist that
you're more likely to wind up with a
nasty populist and he he made this very
dramatic argument that i thought was
incredibly important
which is that we need to reform
capitalism because it's not working for
the bottom 60 percent of americans and
he said this publicly when i was running
for president i was like oh my gosh like
dalio's on board with something dramatic
which he is
and he recommends that you have
essentially a bipartisan manhattan
project trying to fix the economy so
that it works for
the bottom 60 uh of americans uh and he
thought it was an open question whether
the path to get there is that somehow
the two parties get their [ __ ] together
and start collaborating and do something
bipartisan which we all know is highly
unlikely we don't talk about that or
that there's a political realignment
which is what the forward party and i
are trying to make happen right but that
this is the the other the second of the
the two mega cycles which also says
something very very pessimistic and
his diagnosis of it was very familiar to
anyone who's watching where he was like
polarization record highs uh trust
institutions record blows like you know
like everything gets politicized uh
people don't know what the truth is etc
etc so great challenges in terms of the
internal order disorder cycle right and
then the third mega cycle is the rise
and rivalry of different great powers
and so in his
view the u.s is in relative decline in
china is ascending
and that there's going to be increased
friction between those two powers
this book is a bit terrifying andrew do
you risk all your assets buy a bunker
uh well you should you know yeah just
just bring them in bring them in
like just be you know
or just you know yeah like prepare for
some some some not not great things
which you know if you listen to me i
mean you know like we've been saying
[ __ ] like this yeah yeah i mean i've
been on this page you know i'm still
optimistic and can do
which you know i want people to be um
but i also have a clear-eyed view you
know like there are times when
you know you you want to take risks in
time when you want to take a bit less
risk and i'd say this is probably going
to be one of the latter
[Music]
well it's one of the things i think most
people are frustrated and i'm personally
frustrated where you see all this stuff
happening like it's all declining it's
all going this and then you feel like
you can't do anything that's probably a
good way to segue into i want to talk
about some of these the shootings that
are happening we haven't been we haven't
had a chance to talk about on the
podcast yet where it's i mean it's been
going on for ages but uh the most recent
ones tragic shooting buffalo and then
an even worse one in an elementary
school in texas which seems awful and
now it seems since then we have another
shooting every day
um or multiple per day do you mind
breaking this down
the answer to this question andrew is
that
and like a real answer like an andrew
yang answer not like oh because congress
is polarized like did break this down
like we all are generally agree that
this is terrible
yet nothing ever gets done like we don't
change it and like someone be like it's
the nra it's the republicans the special
interests but like
you break that down for me
for us i i do think the political
incentives are very clear and very stark
where there was a republican member of
congress represented buffalo in buffalo
district
and um he came out against chris jacobs
chris jacobs he came out against assault
weapons which by the way frankly if
people get killed by an assault weapon
in your district i would say rational
yeah they had like you know very human
type stance
uh and then took so much
heat and abuse uh uh and outrage that he
said hey i'm not running for congress uh
which he was planning to do
so
do you think other republican members of
congress saw that of course they saw
that and were like well i guess that's
what happened and again this person
represented the community directly yes
so if if you represent another district
and you raise your hand and say hey i
also think that we should look at
banning
uh certain types of weapons that right
now are legal what do you think's gonna
happen to you probably the same or worse
this has happened to
congressman jacobs and he was
essentially told like hey you go i'm out
against this we're going to outflank you
from the right we're going to run
against you on the platform that you're
weak on guns
and he said i mean he said a number of
things publicly but big ones like
there's going to be tens of millions of
dollars pumped into my community talking
about
why we need ar-15s or assault you know
weapons or whatever the heck i'm arguing
against i know that's divisive and awful
not what the community needs so i'm
going to resign is that i mean that's
essentially that's what he said yeah now
i got a call from someone who
works
in
los angeles they said that they were
getting calls as to what they could do
to help and they said the single biggest
move you could make that might help make
congress responsive to this or anything
else would be to ship to open primaries
because if you have a closed party
primary like congressman jacobs goes
through then he looks in and says hey
i'm either going to lose or is it going
to be terrible there's no way in which
this primary does not become terrible so
i am going to resign if you had
it so that everyone in his district
votes on his reelection what percentage
of people in buffalo right now are open
to a move like that you know i'm going
to suggest it it's like
yeah it's probably pretty high it's
certainly much higher than the
proportion of the republican primary
electorate in buffalo uh and so that
this person who called me
made the case which i agree with is that
look if there's one thing you want to
change
it's the primary the party primary
system yes and so this person then is
directing resources to try and shift to
open primaries so that look it like
that's actually the answer and by the
way what i'm saying right now doesn't
apply just to this issue it applies to
just about any
very very fraught or
divisive
issue in the country where you're going
to have some people who are very very
passionate on one end or the other
and then most people will look at it and
say hey there probably is some
reasonable middle ground that most of us
would like to land on
but we're never going to get there
because a lot of people will lose their
job if they compromise and so there is
no compromise
like that this is the fundamental
argument of the forward party which is
look politicians will do whatever their
incentives are and so if their
incentives are to stay in their corner
and say hey you know i'm not going to do
anything because if i do something i
lose my job like this congressman just
did
then guess what they're not going to do
anything right and so like all of the
frustration
passion anger sadness should be directed
towards shifting open primaries because
if there's no change in incentives then
there's no reason why we're going to see
different responses now than we saw
after any other of a number of episodes
so right now you have
house democrats can get a bill through
but the senate can't because they need
it's 50 50 in the senate with colin
harris as a tying vote but you need 60
senators
to get it to get something to vote
through the filibuster filibuster so
that's your issue right there's not and
they're
you know there are republican senators
who are on board with this a bit they're
trying to find something to compromise
on
president biden has suggested
banning assault weapons raising the age
to 21 background checks storage laws and
red flag laws holding manufacturers
accountable which is probably the
toughest one to actually execute and
then the mental health crisis direction
may
actually that's maybe that's the
toughest one to execute on because
that's so dynamic but let's just say we
could
pass laws that would work here what
would work i'm curious your perspective
on the actual policies
uh i think raising the age limit makes a
world of sense yep i think that 18 year
olds brains are at a particular moment
and
uh
it's different than in 21 year olds
brains
and by the way
what are what is like one consistent
fact pattern that we're concerned about
school shooters you know like and so
that's the big one and so it is someone
who's literally a junior senior in high
school you know more prone to go to that
school obviously
uh and so that that seems like something
one of the things i'm discouraged by is
apparently what strikes me as a very
reasonable move of just a three years
for owning an automatic weapon it seems
like republicans don't like that move
right even though that move strikes me
as like right in the heart of okay that
would actually make a difference this is
a clear example of where if you had a
rational political system
uh where people could come together and
say look we can agree on some common
sense measures and let's land here and
draw this line and you know people look
at that and say okay right like that
that that's reasonable that's not the
system we have i mean the the question
now is what can you get 10 republican
senators to agree on
and we're going to find out at least
finals growing up like these debates on
the polarizing issues used to be really
interesting because you could debate
like the policies and what will work and
like
it's fascinating one of the major things
now is that people are just like it
doesn't [ __ ] matter nothing is going
to pass it doesn't matter no point
debating what would the best
effectiveness but but this is the
argument i'm making too is like that
people are waking up
to the fact that this system's totally
dysfunctional and our agreements or
disagreements are increasingly
irrelevant in the face of
what we're seeing
and and so so this is by the way i think
it's going to buy the democrats in the
ass in in november which i guess
everyone knows when there's a failure in
something and so that the one that uh
you know
was top of mind until very recently was
uh women's reproductive rights in rv way
being overturned
and a woman said to me that like you did
not see this firestorm of protest
among certain
groups certain communities
frankly like a lot of
suburban women where the democrats would
look up and say okay it's go time like
let's go fight for
uh women's reproductive rights and they
did not see a giant influx of donations
they did not see an influx
of uh support or activism and i talked
to some people who were within this
community and they're they're just
ticked off
at the democrats for
mismanaging this botching it getting
played
etc and so when these things are
happening when the democrats are raising
their hands and say it's time to fight
by this and that like more and more
people are just being like you can't do
it the system is broken there's nothing
that can be done which by the way is a
case that i have been making uh via the
forward party for a while but that like
that this is materializing in front of
us and i'm going to cautiously say that
the fact that people are waking up to
the realities
of our dysfunctional political system
may be
a good thing that's our silver lining
right there yeah that that like and one
of the arguments i'm making too is like
look you're being played you're being
manipulated yes like 14 billion dollars
went into
both parties
over the last cycle essentially pissing
us off at each other and like you know
and by the way you know how much got
spent in opposition essentially all 14
billion it was like almost 7 billion on
one side and 7 billion on the other so
you have these waves of resources uh and
where does it go essentially nowhere
and so then when someone gets up and
says like hey
like this stuff is going poorly like you
know we need more
more and more people are like no like
that like this stuff is not working
maybe the system is not going to result
in anything positive
and that's savvy so the argument i'm
making is look if you have 14 billion
being spent within the system that's
leading us nowhere good how much should
actually be spent on reforming the
system yeah if you had to put a dollar
figure on it and i'm going to suggest
that number is in the billions yep and
so if you have you had like the
equivalent of a multi-billion dollar and
also giant popular movement towards
trying to reform the system that's
actually the answer for a lot of the
problems i'm describing right now
whether it's
poverty and inflation whether it's guns
uh whether it's
uh social issues
you name it
because most of us actually
are willing to look at it and be like
okay look i'm i'm like i'm on one side
you're on the other side like let's
compromise on something that we can all
be a little unhappy with and go from
there but that's not what the system is
producing
that's probably the silver lining word
i'm a big believer that elections are
about macro issues and usually not micro
issues unless your micro issue is really
really bad to the point where it becomes
a macro issue like if you're seeing the
world crumbling
if you will a country crumbling and just
straight up no action
then you begin to say well it's probably
it becomes a little more obvious to the
casual observer
that it's a system problem and that is
probably good for the forward party and
uh what the challenge is genuine
structural reform yes and it'll be good
it's one of the things i love about the
forward party is that there
theoretically will be someone
and multiple someone's to do kind of
what you did in the presidential was
like raise your hand like hey it's
actually the system that's busted here
and it's like what you're two talking
about like
is stupid on both sides and actually
doesn't matter and you're right that's
the other thing the truth usually will
scale here um because you're right and
over time like this whole
this is already panning out will
continue to pan out because we have a
school shooting
everybody's pissed off and heartbroken
and and just angry and then nothing gets
done you saw it with george floyd saw
ruby wade saw the school shooting we're
gonna see with climate change we're
gonna see with wall street being corrupt
in 2008 where ceos
get paid and no one goes jail like you
get it on the list people are angry
about something that happened
eventually i think they'll get fed up i
think two things happen you either get
fed up or you get it or you ignore it
well well one of the things i'd say is
like if people who take a step back and
check out on this stuff like i totally
get it i mean you know it's like why
would you willingly allow yourself to be
upset all the time yeah you know i spent
some time with um
some family over memorial day weekend
and the husband and wife were in two
different camps one was like radicalized
to one side i'll just ignore so they
don't share their belief but they're one
side where they you know the other party
was evil and this is what i'm passionate
about i got really really passionate and
then the other side in this case the
husband was just tuned out just any time
his wife brought it up he's like walking
out of the room i'm not talking politics
and that's to me was like america in a
nutshell in a way like we've either
become really really angry about
something and we've tried to help or
we're just like f this i'm gonna go down
my own and do my own thing and not care
about it and
you could argue both are somewhat
uh equally destructive in a way well one
of the arguments i made months ago which
i still believe is that we are slumping
towards autocracy
you tweet that that's fun
i i i something tell me what you mean by
that well
it's just that uh we're trending towards
authoritarianism
and then when someone tries to be like
hey you know no get up and fight like
this everyone will be like yeah whatever
yeah like like that that's
uh that's the general direction we're
heading
we had this learning when we were
running for president where um
you know trump was such a good example
of this but it was what you call the
post-inspirational america where
obama ran on hope and change people are
so passionate so idealistic about what
we could do and then
he could only do what he could in this
busted system
uh and to the point where like the
platitudes were just worthless like you
could say we're gonna
you know we're gonna change i will say
this as an iron who did vote for obama
yeah when i see him show up in my
netflix queue i'm like actively
discouraged or whatever yeah i'm just
like this is where we are now
like you mean him as a hollywood
producer oh yeah so he just shows up and
like you know he's he's like uh he's a
mythical figure at this point you know
but you know he's getting and this is
maybe my biggest beef with obama
is that like he truly was president as
cultural figure
uh and
he's still a cultural figure
but i'm not sure that's what we need
right now you know what i mean like uh
yeah well look i mean if you're obama
like like we don't need good content is
what i'm saying it's like we don't know
it's like like will
and this is by you know i i mean like
you know like i i really did like uh
american factory like i liked you know
like but but it's like you know that
that [ __ ] will not set us free at this
point i mean you have like you know
you have the system that's just freaking
overrun with uh
cash in various ways and and then the
cash
is made by inflaming us in in uh various
directions and so being a practical
sword i'm like okay you know what we
need we need
cash that rewards
people thinking yeah yeah like you know
like depolarizing
messages and behaviors and that and the
rest of it and which you know maybe
maybe that's no i think if you're
i was at this if i was a billionaire
right now i would spend
it sounds dark but i probably would look
to
buy the system out for good which
obviously who am i to say that but you
look to go
kind of what bloomberg tried to do
because the only way to do is pour money
into
like the broken system so there's
democracy reform or you're just
straight-up buying senators and
congressmen and women who are on
i i propose a legislator uh liberation
fund which is which is that we will buy
you out of your contract with the major
party like what did you spend in the
last cycle 20 million we will give you
that plus 50 so 30 million dollars to
join this to be a rational human being
yeah yeah to be an independent
essentially you could just go down the
line and buy i actually believe it or
not everyone i price this out like you
you get a couple billion um it's less
you know it's not even that much you
don't need that many senators yeah you
could buy out four u.s senators from
their contracts with their
um with their parties for less than 200
million i'm assuming you're making this
pitch
[Laughter]
is this a real pitch yeah this is a real
pitch this should be a pitch uh it's a
good pitch
okay so i i think i've said this on the
podcast before i talked to someone who
used to be very very senior at the world
bank and i was at uh my former job on
wall street and she asked uh all of the
our big clients at like a small dinner
we were having like if you could had all
the money in the world to solve a social
problem what would you do and people
were like education this and and then i
flipped it on her i'm like what would
you do she said i would get it in cash
and use it to pay off the bribe people
for good
because she's like most of the world's
problem this is a bigger problem
internationally but it's a big part of
the united states too where it's just
it's all about the money so it's it goes
like the decisions that are made but
they help people hurt people are made
frankly for the highest bidder and we
learned that when we ran it's like
don't kid yourself it's all money game
it's all money game
so i i want to try and unlock a critical
mass of resources to do what i'm
describing yeah it's good fun
i'm enjoying it you know we're the
worthy fight for sure i mean we're you
know we're we're in the like seven
figures so you know like you're cranking
yeah and you're and the other thing is
you guys will unlock other
like they may be like oh i don't know
about the forward party but i do believe
in the ideas so here's a four party
competitor or whatever like i'm sure
you'll see that nonsense too but that's
good you normalize what you're talking
about ideally we all line up but well
you know i mean i see like you said if
you were a billionaire let's say andrea
was a billionaire which by the way
everyone knows i mean it's like
laughable
you were for a little bit that would be
great stuff but like would i fund a
legislative liberation fund sure you
know would i would i go around and you
could do a lot of good in this direction
and one of my frustrations with a couple
of people who tiptoed in this direction
so here are these people ross perot
howard schultz mike bloomberg where
when they did their thing they didn't
then turn around and invest in the deep
structural reform
um they left pissed off
yeah and it's like look the process
sucks get it i've actually been through
versions of it um but let's do the
entrepreneur thing and like build the
uh alternative and like build the
counter set of incentives and you know
there hasn't been that appetite but the
appetite's returning because everyone
sees how screwed up the current system
is yeah um so that that's uh you know
again we earlier in this conversation he
said look 14 billion got spent within
the system how much is getting spent to
perform the system
you know if we spent
a billion dollars trying to reform the
system we'd do a ton of good yep
so aoc i think it was on twitter i saw
it on twitter i don't know if she did it
on instagram live or something but i
don't always agree with her on a lot of
things
but
she said something that resonated with
me she said it's really really difficult
to operate
in a system that's fundamentally corrupt
and it's one of the things you notice
too he's like i can go into congress and
i'm gonna do [ __ ] yeah and then i just
get reduced to like a freaking
off-broadway theater performer which is
what you know like most of them become
um but this is also an argument that
really fueled the
the origin of the forward parties that
ezra klein said toxic systems
compromised good individuals with ease
yeah and he was ease and he was making
that argument like it it's a toxic
system yes like you we got to clean the
system up one of the fascinating
elements is like you know we gotta
you know we're gonna need money to clean
the system up so like i'm trying to get
righteous money
which is fun and and there actually are
people who i believe fall into this
category including you know people are
listening to this who've given us ten
bucks i mean that's right just money
where right just money grassroots
dollars are you that's the most
righteous yeah but i will say to you
because no one feels like it's my you
know i don't know i i will say to you
all though we're gonna need a
combination of like grassroots and some
other stuff yeah you need more than
because that's the thing burn let's call
bernie the king of grassroots funding
right
what's he raised over all the elections
200 million all in maybe
probably being oh it is another thing
one of my one of my more controversial
tweets or whatever i was like bernie
should have started a third party which
i by the way totally believe yeah oh
yeah and there were a lot of people who
were part of the bernie movement who
wanted him to yes and i don't know why
he didn't um but he would have had a
shot at it
so we're going to close this
convo on an uplifting note so zach
how has it been being a published author
over the last couple weeks that's not
bad man i will say
i think i've talked about this on the
podcast like
books are an interesting thing to be
selling
i think i've met a lot of first-time
authors and i worked with you very
closely when you were a second time
author and pretty close to your third or
third author but i would say a lot of
people a lot of authors have that
ambition that they're going to sell lots
of books and i'll like the world on fire
and be a new york times bestseller i had
none of those those ambitions i will say
for those of you who have um
a lot of you have reached out both to me
personally or on social media saying i
read the book i love it that's been nice
to hear it's a great book if you haven't
picked it up everyone long shot how
political nobody's made andrew yang
president united states it's more
uplifting
it's more uplifting than ray's book it
sounds like
i don't have a research team
and do that [ __ ] myself it also is more
fun and readable and cinematic than my
book so that's true it's more of a
narrative we're trying to we're trying
to make a movie out of it in a way yeah
so so if you want to
see essentially like a movie screenplay
about like the
uh madcap yang campaign um check out
longshot and
as someone who's written a few books
that the
frame i put myself in after the first
book was like look as long as like you
are happy with what you produced and
that people you respect
uh say to you like hey good job then
you're golden yeah that's pretty
absolutely yeah those people have read
it that i like and trust are like
i really enjoyed this like no they'll
say like look i would tell you but i
enjoyed it that's good
so on this topic
it is now the beginning of summer and uh
what content recommendations summer
content rex
i have some
i just finished the first part of season
four of stranger things i got i'm a you
watch stranger things yes i [ __ ] love
stranger things i think it's well done
and i didn't love this season the whole
time that was a little dramatic
and then they i thought they ended you
watch the newest one i thought they
ended it really well and they closed a
bunch of loop a lot of not all of them a
lot of loopholes from the first season
like kind of stuff you've been having
throughout i'm going to loved it match
your stranger things and raise you with
the boys season three i haven't watched
it yet it's good yeah it's really good
boys are good i mean it's dark it's
messed up but it's messed up in that in
that
delight fun boys way hilarious way yeah
for those of you who haven't heard of
the boys on amazon it's about
i guess like if you had superheroes that
became if you had real superheroes in
the world of capitalism there is a lot
of capitalism critique going on um it's
like watchmen but a less that is less
dark than watchmen and it's a little
more realistic right i mean
it's a great watch that's good the boys
check it out i'm going to go with a
couple of deep cuts for people going out
there man summer content also from
amazon prime if you like the boys
there's an animated series called
invincible oh i said it's good that's i
saw it that's excellent oh yeah it's
really really good
uh all right so also you know i mean
like i stephen yanu i'm friends with is
like the lead voice actor in invisible
invincible is just a great freaking show
if you like the boys and you want more
like that the invincibles in some ways
almost like an animated version called
voice also on amazon prime also super
enjoyable reacher
jack creature the jack reach i think
it's called reacher but it's there's a
giant blonde dude now
so tom cruise movie turned into a series
right yes so so it's based on a series
of books right this show is really fun
and watchable
uh so if you have amazon prime after you
get through the boys invincible and
reacher
uh both
really
really like
high quality in my opinion really good
watches i've i finished ozark it's good
last season really i love jason i've
always liked jason bateman uh laura
lenny's really talented she's annoying
in this show but she's supposed to be
brown university i don't know if you're
really yeah nice uh that's right well
one of two actors coming out how many
actors come out of brown oh a lot of
people come out of brown really i know a
lot of people like you know towns of
people going right i don't know i guess
you've got a creative probably most
famous uh emma watson
she's a brown grad yep all right i'm
watching two things right now i'm
watching the last kingdom
which is on netflix now
which i've heard is really good i
haven't gotten into it yet i'm gonna
probably get into marvel and that's my
brother wants me to get into uh or like
the disney plus
uh marvel series so that's uh what is it
wand division and loki and
mixed bag honestly are they so i i was a
comic book dude growing up so i've seen
all the marvel stuff okay and it's a
mixed bag okay i'm not a lot but on
netflix
another deep cut
that i so it's funny it's like i was
looking for stuff i could watch with my
my sons and it turns out that this was
too dark for them
but it's called arcane it's based upon a
video game
an animated series and it's freaking
excellent like it's too dark for the
beautiful it was funny it's like i was
looking for something we could watch as
a family and then it ends up being me
and evelyn watching it um but it's
nuanced narratives uh great characters
uh arcane if you like
that kind of thing it's kind of kind of
gotten anime style okay so carly my
fiance is
obsessed obsessed with the show gilmore
girls so i've
been begged to watch the show many many
times so i've eventually caved and now i
use it as like if she's mad at me i'll
be like we could just watch gilmore
girls right and that has earned me some
points but i will say it's not bad it's
actually not bad at least this usually
has pretty witty dialogue i'd argue the
lead actresses are pretty talented um
i've watched a lot of gilmore girls and
i don't know if that's i don't know if i
should put i don't know if i want to say
that
plus you know it does feel good it's
generally feel good but it's funny
because it's back it's shot back when
shows were done like in a studio and you
wouldn't binge watch them you know um so
it's and it was like you know one hour
episodes 20 episodes a season so there's
a lot of it yeah i mean i like watching
that stuff because i remember
i not that i saw that you know in real
time but like just times were simpler at
a particular point yeah it's like yeah i
don't know i haven't gone back and
watched the oc but i imagine that was
the show that is associated the most in
my mind with the simpler time is friends
oh yeah because because you know it's
like the entire dating life in your 20s
in new york city or whatever it's like i
was watching that [ __ ] when i was in
college and then i moved here and then
it was like that's what you like you
imagine life's going to be like and it's
totally not but
it's simple but it was simple it's
simpler times there's your racks folks
plus both zach and i
get need to get out there and see top
gun that's our page
you got to see it i've heard all right
say this
i've had a number of friends be like top
gun sick top gun sick my family said top
gun sick the fact the fact that anyone
could ever in the same sentence say it
top the new top gun is as good if not
possibly better than the original that
may not be true but the fact that they
could say it without sounding like an
idiot
means it's probably pretty awesome it is
your patriotic duty to go out and see
top gun coming from a guy who has not
seen it yet but that's a fine way to
close honestly i think this
this episode let's get our summers on
and look
things are challenging out there but
just like look outside
uh look in your loved ones faces
you know the sun is shining life is good
so let's get out and enjoy it later
y'all
you